i've made a lot of sacrifices in my life  and i'm not asking anybody to feel sorry  for me i'm i do know though that the  first  the first trick to success  is not what you learned  [Music]  you don't need to buy a course for me  if you want to be successful  and some guy heard some guys saying  cardone's trying to sell a course okay  that's not the first step to success  though first step is  you have to give something up  you have to give up something about who  you are  you want to solve a problem you got to  give up the idea that you you've either  tried every way possible or you don't  know you know that you've already tried  that and that's not going to work or  it's not you got to give something up  my whole life is different today because  i continue to be willing to give stuff  up  in 25 it was drugs i had to get drugs up